this video explains how to make comments
on the proposed submission team bridge
local plan 2020-204c
the live consultation team bridge local
plan web page contains links to all of
the consultation documents including the
proposed submission local plan
if you wish to make comments on any of
the consultation documents so scroll
down this page until you see the start
button
to begin adding your comments click the
start button
to comment you can log in with your
teambridge my account
you can either create a my account or
continue without one
please note that if you do not have a my
account you will not be able to save and
return to your comments later
before you are able to proceed you need
to read the Privacy notices
by pressing continue you are agreeing to
the conditions set out in this notice
please select whether you are an agent
acting on behalf of someone else
or making your own comments
if you are an agent making comments on
behalf of someone else please fill in
both sets of contact details
if you are filling in your own form
please include all your contact details
as requested we cannot accept Anonymous
representations at this stage of the
local plan process
you will need to select whether you wish
to comment on the local plan or
Community infrastructure Levy
from the drop down menu please select
which part of the local plan or which
consultation document you wish to
comment on
you can comment on specific aspects of
the local plan
the whole local plan other consultation
documents or supporting evidence
you must then select which policy or
proposal you would like to comment on in
the drop down menu
you are asked to comment whether you
consider the plan or policy to be
legally compliant
there are many tests of legal compliance
such as whether a plan Accords with
national legislation has been properly
consulted on during its preparation and
has taken account of comments received
you are asked to comment whether you
consider the plan or policy to be sound
the national planning policy framework
sets out the tests of soundness to be
one whether the plan has been positively
prepared and meets the area's
development needs
two whether the plan is Justified being
based on evidence and considering
reasonable alternatives
three whether the plan is effective and
enables sustainable development
and four whether the plan is consistent
with national planning policy
you are asked to consider whether the
plan complies with the duty to cooperate
this juicy ensures that neighboring
authorities and certain statutory
organizations are involved during the
preparation of the plan
consider that the plan does not meet
these three requirements you must
explain your reasons why
if you have completed question three
you can also set out any modifications
that you consider would need to be
needed to make the plan legally
compliant or sound
once you have written your comments you
will need to press the add comments
button
when you have added all your comments
you will need to press the next button
to continue
Community infrastructure Levy or sill
draft charging schedule
review the proposed changes and
indicates whether you agree or not
you will be asked if you wish to appear
at the examination hearing that will be
held by an independent planning
inspector
if you choose not to appear at the
hearing your comments will still be
considered by the inspector
before you submit your comments you will
be asked to complete some information
about yourself
you can choose whether to provide this
information or not you must then click
the submit button to send us your
comments
thank you for watching this video